this is a  level 158 Pepper Panic Saga walkthrough video by Pepper Panic Tips
in the walkthrough i'm gonna play
the
level, it's a tough level that actually was probably the toughest in
episode 11 and the one that gave players
the most problems
it's difficult because the statues are away from things
in the corners and
there six colors of peppers on the board
it's very hard to
make matches and get things to grow
in the beginning is you don't want to
get rid of the cages so in the end is
kinda wanna make a lil
look around see what color is the
store with the best colors are yellow
looks like it's the best
and purple looks like it's the worst
because there's no purple
workers trapped in the cages so see you
in New
arm in the beginning I'm just gonna be
growing peppers a match this one first
because and so that the next match
yellow and I got lucky in your
next yr luxury lol deal
trying to get the roads in a and shapes
working make you know
you know there's only one draft red one
it still a good thing too grow that
rather than the purple
a at times you're going to have to grow
the purple again other ways
this is what happens when those this
many colors
the room
just swore to your check the board to
make sure the
you're not missing out on a big match
the
you it's nice to clear the ISO if we do
master pulls out a bit on
they just want to use anywhere in the
world
ligaments in the old looks to be the
best colours so
we my
world mister
I 1 I'm headin way in one move there
because they were in the fear I can get
some other things to happen below
not a great result but I we have this
one down to move on we've also overcame
there and rego
warm on both barth them
home
through to see it now this is a good
nice because
its and will get a chain reaction that
take up that one and hopefully get them
for certain
the right before
but we're in a pretty good spot here we
can keep that one up there for a second
we have seventy move and
we need four hits total
I always look to the bottom report first
but in this case there's really no
law
over merge this one year so I can
military action star your okay so now we
have
the two artists taxes on the board
here this is where you want to preserve
your kid care
it's not the end of the world but
this is gonna be substantially harder
than weird
pages a min ago and match the order them
you 30 cascade see what happens we go on
that's good a
whenever you have one statue at the top
you always want to
try to set up a shockwave obviously
you can see here that this line goes all
the way across and there's definitely no
way to set one up so
you can really count on these colors to
be here
by the time that you actually get you
know
we don't have any grown papers really it
also in this one here they're so
you can really when you're matching your
lose these ones that are set by here
anyway so I will just have to grow the
color the fastest switches
you know me that I'll manage their crew
the green
and it also drew this yellow
here
and a.m.
that's really with this many colors and
you really can't plan all that much
better than that I'm
I'm gonna clear this rotary
here because going early balloon and see
where things go on
credible again
like to be able to go growth yellow on
this %uh the board because then I could
I can probably get this one to explode
but
Europe
under the school are that'll do it
that's the way you have to think about
you just want to
turkey many cases all
became and when when you can't use after
you know just here thinking based on
what's available hope this will help you
out
if you're stuck on the level it's
difficult but it's definitely beatable
I think this was my third try so
this hang in there and all the tension
are forgotten
make sure you like us on Facebook and
if you have any questions leave a
comment and we'll get back to you right
away
thanks